on va commencer par le steampunk
est ce que vous connaissez le thème ces
derniers temps david organisateurs et
galiériste s'improvise guide
régulièrement
c'est un pan de la science fiction n'est
pas d'accord et on part de l'idée que on
s'est arrêté à peu près à l'époque
victorienne mans en pleine révolution
industrielle
une période décliné dans des visions
futuristes
en temps de qu'ovide la culture en
extérieur s'avère donc pratique et cela
plaît des peintures vraiment très très
original un style vraiment méconnu pour
moi qui suis vraiment novice en la
matière donc c'est super intéressant de
voir des grandes oeuvres comme ça sur
des grandes bâches au milieu de la ville
c'est super depuis un mois chacun peut
découvrir au détour d'une rue des
représentations de différents styles et
notamment de science fiction avec le
maître absolu en la matière le créateur
du vaisseau du dix30 et un lacet monde
sur mon jeu c'est le meilleur parti de
science fiction au monde et il est
français il fait beaucoup de couvertures
de bouquins là c'en est une par exemple
il travaille aussi dans le domaine
scientifique
les exoplanètes il a travaillé on
attrayant ensemble sur la mission
insight qui a lieu actuellement sur mars
près d'une trentaine d'artistes est
ainsi représenté auteur pour la jeunesse
ou pour l'heroic fantasy ce monde
médiéval qui éveille l'imaginaire
[Musique]
quand je dors des fois pas je vois des
dragon qui crache du feu et du coup et
bah c'est pour ça que j'aime bien les
dragons on voit des repères qu'on a déjà
là je voyais un peu ça me fait penser à
la belle et la bête où j'ai vu des
vaisseaux qui me faisait penser à
albator ce genre de choses
attention il ne vous reste que deux
jours pour découvrir ces mondes
fantastiques